la révolution on s'occupe de nos chères
têtes blondes
le ministre de l'éducation a expliqué
qu'il s'agissait surtout d'éviter les
redoublements il y aura deux cycles de
trois temps
autre changement une semaine de 26
heures les 27 autres décisions encore
qu'il n'y aura pas forcément le samedi
matin ça dépendra de la décision les
enseignants et des lions du club cette
formule pour l'école primaire a déjà été
expérimenté dans certaines classes par
exemple à trappes dans les yvelines
chantal kimmerlin pavillon retour à la
morale chacun se rattraper le niveau de
la terre contre seulement 32 places
chaque programme est très bien rodée
l'équipe du prix de chaque écolier alors
les instituteurs